they are lost to Kelly Clarkson  everything that changed  no one wanted to be on my team ever  again shut up  [Music]  I was cooler when I was 16 and I had now  I have most definitely was not I peaked  few years ago singers for more singers  single max thought of it's 5 I thought  there were five points Cinco means five  okay  Quatro means force like yeah your  Spanish right I kind of thing when I  sneeze I'm on a track it's like wow I  can't even sneeze in front of people it  was real me in front of people cuz when  I do I don't know what's gonna happen  everything goes everywhere hey guys I  caught up on the butthurt convention  over here up on it  oh we know we didn't think we're gonna  get them we need to make sure you're  just having fun  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]